we were looking at this whole idea of
division by zero is undefined it's a
trafficking so I want to pursue this
just a little bit more together this
idea that Matt's like we come to it as
this established timeless body of truth
that's always be the same but actually
that's not always the way it was and so
I'm gonna take you in a bit of a time
journey through this okay idea sheet
myself so we're looking at a very very
brief history of number systems that's
kind of young its kind of real heading
today no you probably don't need to make
the heading in your book because I think
that you can pretty much fit it all on
that page okay but I don't have it up on
the board so I'm gonna right now number
systems okay
now let's think through this right I've
got these columns here to help us think
through what kinds of numbers exist and
and why do they exist and why might that
be unusual like we're used to these
things but not everyone in history used
to be so we'll begin with tallying tally
right this is the greenery or unary
system right which is just about one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
right this system okay so tell me why do
you think why do you think you know
whatever prehistoric humans came up with
this idea why did they invent this way
off hey look this is five things and
this means another five feet so it's all
Tim why would they done yeah yeah yeah
good aha
it's all about that's the crucial idea
it's all about counting isn't it right
because counting is something that we do
all the time
good uh-huh yes well time so it's a bit
more sophisticated than just one two
three four five now by the way why do
you think it's grouped into five because
actually like we're used to dealing with
fives but five actually very awkward
number like 5 is prime you know if you
have a group of five people so you can't
divide it up into anything's right I
think the reason why it's five is
because five like I think it's because
of human hands well anyway that's my
theory
okay so why was this system invented was
to make counting easier right as me for
counting right but this system to us
it's weird we were dumb excuse me thank
you
we would never do maths with this right
oh can you imagine if we were doing like
x squared plus 1 2 3 4 5 x plus 1 2 3 4
5 6 like we would have dude this is the
quartet could get you before equals
we'll come to that in a second oh we
wouldn't do maths like this right
why what's the limitation of this system
hmm okay we will come to 0 which is this
that's what I was going to put any here
but there's even more is a more basic
problem with it yeah yes so like let's
think of the school for instance right
some 2000 whatever students okay so it's
like all right in my age of school
report I have to write down happenes to
say you're like okay hold on guys it's
gonna be here for a while right so this
system unary system the tally system
that's the other name for it it's weird
because well after like 10 it's nice
just to you fro just to write the
numbers let alone do anything with them
okay so in other words this system it
doesn't cope with large numbers very
well it doesn't cope with large numbers
okay so along come the Romans and they
decide we can improve on this we can
improve on this we can have revenue
models right okay so what do Roman
numerals do better than this system what
do they do what are the remedies so I
tell you all right good so that's just
one so that's that's that's
one gotta be careful with this what's
next after that v45 okay what comes out
to that ex full ten okay how far we go
and all I think yeah okay then seed for
a hundred oh hold on what's the eighty
five hundred and then Jim is a thousand
is there anything make it look the witch
oh okay okay all right all right but
basically that's that's the basic set
isn't yeah good okay so so why is this
better in what way is this an
improvement on this system it's easier
but why is it easier yeah fantastic very
good
you remember my scenario before about
the population of school right that's
really easy to do then ah well I mean
roughly okay this would have taken me
hours to write in in italia system okay
so the revenue was just to you add
letters that stand for large numbers and
that speeds up this process enormously
okay all right now I want you to imagine
you're one of these guys one of these
guys who's grown up with these forever
but you've no nothing else
and then someone comes in and says hey I
have a new system right this is the way
we're going to represent numbers what
would you say to them what is it like
that's a weird system because that's
unusual about it and you're so used to
it think about before these were a
common theme yeah lettuce lettuce like
by the way these letters right they were
not extra symbols they were you know L
was still L right so when you saw L you
had to work out where there was 50 or it
was L right so it seems a bit arbitrary
to pick these out there are reasons for
these by the way they don't know why
it's me it's probably because you can
make a V with your hand with five one
zero five right X that's a bit weird ah
see
see we know what this is for C stands
for century said century and all the
things with a hundred
right but then the profit it's like a
bit it starts to get a bit rain of an
arbitrary you just have to work it out
whereas you can show one of these two
like a little baby and they don't even
know what these are they can count right
so this is intuitive and this is random
right like who says it was it had to be
helped
why not like you know tea and the extras
no reason because they just started
using Elm
right so so that's a bit weird okay um
why should letters represent numbers
that's confusing
now there's still a problem here right
I'm sure we can do 2000 you can do 2000
but you can't go to the moon with
numbers like this right why what's the
problem with this system yeah good good
so as you keep on going up it's like hey
man I'm running out of letters only got
wait note him there that's 7 I've only
got 19 letter left and then what happens
when your bigger numbers than that right
that's true
let me get a normal functional problem
right so this is moving to be placed
system facebones right this is the next
room yeah okay let me pose this problem
to you can you work out for me let's see
can you work out this
I had to write times so you didn't use
it with exit multiplication can you wake
that up now ah ha ha ha I caught all of
you right admittedly it's a bit weird
advice because you have not grown with
revenues but what do you all do E you're
thinking oh I know what this is
that's 59 right and that's 16 and then
you're working out like that aren't she
right you're deliberately escaping from
this way of writing because it's like
how do you multiply these things how do
you divide them this is just a nightmare
to work with
whereas this even without a calculator
you can work this out right how would we
do it by the way my calculators how did
you do it how would you yeah yeah good
you'd say okay you know 50 times 16
you'd work out that yes are you working
you work it out how many do 9 times 6
plus 9 times 16 you can work that out as
well and off you go okay so you can
break this down but you can't break down
this you can't break down the Roman
numerals right because you can't say oh
I'll do the L x times 9 X right and then
I'll do the I times that V that's that's
confusing because you know you guys know
this eye and this eye they mean
different things don't they
what does this I mean my next money this
one means right okay so so context
changes things right and that makes it
awful for actually doing any operations
okay so you can do bigger numbers but
here's the problem right this is my um
this is my my idea for why these things
were invented right why were numbers
like 59 and 17 right why are they
invented to make operations easier so
you can work with numbers okay Roman
numerals is nice for recording stuff and
that's right looks fancy at the end of a
movie
they write the here in Roman numerals
cousin looks fancy right but if you want
to do this stuff with the numbers you
gotta leave her and do it
now tell me Romans who are used to Roman
numerals you've grown up with them for
years what's weird about this okay with
that numbers but okay so wait we've got
a new set of symbols that's a bit weird
but I think this is something
fundamentally more weird about it and it
has to do with this whole place idea
yeah yeah that's weird
look at this 2 2 2 2 right
if you gave this to a Roman and they
have a symbol for two they'd say that 8
because if you put two in two in two and
two together if I have sets of two zd8
that's why you're telling me this too is
different to that to presume at the back
they are all true what are you crazy
right so this is weird because just
because you changed the position right
they mean different things that's
unusual none of the other systems will
really like that look
all of these Pataki's wherever they are
they mean exactly the same thing okay
even this horizontal one he's in a
different spot he still means one right
so this place a system that's weird okay
yeah this is a really good question
that's really questions I can tell you
right now not in the same way we did and
there's a lot more awkward because of
the limitations in system
okay so now we move on anyone you want
to zero right
why was zero invented this is actually
really easy to work out some of your
Roman numerals right yeah
aha well see okay so this is a very very
good question to ask and I think that's
the right question asked things like L
I'll step suffer that X or L or C or D
or M when we write them
we have zeros there right so I think of
river would say hey you fancy people we
do place values right how you gonna ride
see huh how you gonna do it
you're like you've got a hundred and
then you've got nothing over here right
never simple for that you'd need a
symbol for nothing that's a bit weird
right so one got invented right what are
you thinking zero looks like that by the
way because most cultures zeros look
very same very similar why do you think
zero looks like zero yeah I think that's
right I think it's like look there's
nothing here look there's nothing there
I'll just bet there's nothing I just
circled nothing inside there there's
nothing there
okay there's another nothing there I
just put a semi there so you know
nothing's there okay
so zero is invented to account you know
sort of fix up that problem that I have
to write something the one just can't
hang out on this phone right because
otherwise it just means one idea unit
but it's weird because how can you have
a number for nothing like it started we
it started with tally and counting right
if you don't have anything you don't
tally anything right you don't need to
write anything but when you introduce
pace values you must okay so it was to
to get numbers like this right in place
might inform you leads Europe all right
I reckon you guys could answer the next
one for me I'd only miss you fractions
and decimal what problem do you think
fractions and decimals were devised to
solve what stuff in between
right so for instance right yeah a set
of twenty-four things and you want to
divide it amongst six people no problems
for you for you and you get what if you
don't have six people you wanna divide
over to you what if you have five people
which is just as common and occurrence
right it's like we you don't get whole
pieces you get numbers between numbers
okay so fraction this was they were
invented because of problems like this
right usually things are invented like
what are inventions for we invented
light because solves problems right well
electricity I can I think how to use it
right and we invent numbers for the same
thing we have a problem we need to solve
it so you invent ways to do that but it
is weird because the idea of numbers
between though this is unusual right and
it takes a very long time when you're
going from let you 6070 you right it
takes a lot of times we will wrap their
heads around and the maths of it right
like two plus three is five but 1/2 plus
1/3 is not a fetus right it seems to
follow different rules right and they
did because they're different kinds of
numbers